[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
get up there
okay nowhere
let's finish this
[Music]
[Music]
your turn to report fatalities l9 11240
reporting in
we've got confirmed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
than we thought
sounds our home looking badly damaged
bread 70% integrity and falling
that's just filthy enough to stop of
these insurgents actually worked
[Music]
that's plasters
hey who are you
someone are just brought now that to the
table who are you
some will make the Empire we're
venturing an employee battle ahead with
my five points that make them even
angrier
personal
yam okay you all right you know you're
not doing that again you just wrecked
the perfectly good walk got a name calc
Estes sovereign what are you doing on
Kashyyyk looking for somebody
what are you doing here my companions
and I came to catch sheep too disruptive
pill supply lines
[Music]
[Applause]
so who are you looking for lucky
chieftain named tarfful awful is
impossible fine there's a reason he's
ready to be Empire for this law he's a
freedom fighter
he's the freedom fighter a symbol of the
bookie resistance
striking at the Empire full of shadow
lays sear grease this is all how you
doing what do you want with toffee Jedi
business Jedi obtain not all of them get
there over corpse and Master gave it to
me
dispatch supports an appeal refinery
that runs a Wookiee slave labor Intel
suggests that some of the captors there
a guerrilla fighters I should help them
one of them might know how to contact
tarfful it's possible
whoa wait a minute hold on wait a minute
the Manas works wonders I mean it's
great ship excellent pilot but it is not
built for close support we'll stay here
and monitor Imperial transmissions the
bit of luck will intercept any distress
calls appreciate it
my lieutenants and I will scout ahead to
prepare the attack join us when you're
ready go go
[Music]
[Music]
but you're alright yeah yeah good to see
you too this place is a dump
your plan worked and now you want to
follow us all
you don't like that idea I'm concerned
you're jumping from one risk to the next
wait what I fly my ship in the middle of
a battlefield and now we're talking
about risks why didn't you stop me my
job is to guide you on your path not
choose it for you so here's my advice
the Empire's overtaken hundreds of
worlds
there's a reason sought chose to she
saws goals may not be the same as ours
we should be careful Thanks
I'll keep that in mind
over here could be supplies inside this
Walker okay I'm I'm fine
true I'm fine
[Music]
sascha be on the other end of the
stretch
[Music]
right I need another power source
look a workbench
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll check it out how much current can
you conduct well with this transformer I
bet you can short-circuit Imperial Tech
[Music]
let's try it
[Music]
[Music]
Thanks
[Music]
over here
your supper finally lies dead ahead -
the Empire won't with tree sap another
good they refine the SAP into a powerful
compound and a Russian to expand
production
we have to stop them has to play we
don't love her in game they spread
themselves too late
this map we've covered proves these
refineries double his brutal prison
camps use those cutters to create a
distraction while you take your
lightsaber in freedom walkies inside we
need their help to stop the Empire
understood watch yourself in there you
hear them saying use my help breathe
lovely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rather slice into this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looks like you plotted out rates Ted
never see the trooper like that before
think you can help me beat
[Music]
plane beetles they're coming through the
wall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you sure you want to plug into this
thing okay
shortcut that's why you wanted to move
this thing you had no idea that was
there did you we just wanted to turn
that cutter on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
another one
[Music]
[Music]
the Jedi will be here any minute and our
reinforcements in retreat good sir the
fewer distractions the better
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as I am The Emperor's will
traitor
[Music]
[Music]
can't get through guards
[Music]
[Music]
for you
[Music]
visitation is not
[Music]
[Music]
games play best on Xbox one
[Music]
you